man you more like man me hi Joe say
that's quite an outfit it's very
decorative if he's the most decorative I
am the most decorated manager seriously
they think he's garden gnome of a
manager's better than me how are you
terrible I could use a massage my centre
back is killing me so the object of this
game is you try to score once and then
after that you sit back and wait for
time to run out it's the best way to
waste 90 minutes what are they doing
they seem to be plainly peeing but they
have this upside down frowns and they
are making sounds like ha ha ha it's
called smiling and having fun overrated
don't get any ideas
Oh a special one that means I get to
throw a player under the bus let's see
so many choices how about don't want to
play this anymore you won't play where I
say you play Paul Paul I'm kidding I
only say this because you're my favorite
right now the show is good people are
happy wait until season 3 things to go
very bad truly are my greatest rival you
can never clap oh you are mine you
brilliant Paul barcelonian oh I'm your
rival I'm everyone to rival I'm the most
decorated I'll be your rival Josie not
you I've gathered you all here to remind
you that just because you are not good
it doesn't mean we can't have a good
time now enjoy your mandatory mirror hmm
these all appear to be top-quality
voyeur I won't taste them because I know
they are not as good as the chosen ones
I made three times in fourth and last
place you you you and especially you
Paul you should all be disappointed can
we go coach
you're no problem you're alone to me
whoa hey what are you doing here Simon
told me that this belt II needed new
energy you were not invited
go away what's the matter Luke not
enough cholesterol is for you they have
a bigger role I don't get her Maguire
you don't get more food special ones
back up the Premier League is ready for
more
yo hey it's okay I am here now and
remember it could always be worse three
whole years before that happens and by
then you'll be longer I'll be truthful
man together with one man united knows
this cartoon it is the special one of
cartoons
so park your bus right here and show
your respect by subscribing